time for our scene and unseen segment
will we reveal the stories behind the
headlines and for that would turn to fox
news contributor raymond arroyo was a
special report on crime and drug use in
new york city laura you have been
covering the connection between even
recreational drug use like marijuana and
crime well here in new york city mayor
eric adams has long been a proponent of
marijuana use
one of my best gifts as you know
marijuana is legal i have one i did not
know i have raw i am not aware mr mayor
i'm not into that scene i have bamboo oh
there's an egg
and i can't give you this gift i'll give
it to you later you know
now laura no matter where you go in this
city even in the morning as we did the
other day drugs are everywhere people
are brazenly using all manner of
substances right out in the open and
drug use is not the only thing rising
since last year crime has exploded here
in new york city rapes are up 27
robberies 33 percent and now the mayor
has a new idea to teach people how to
use drugs safely kind of a tutorial he's
instituted the plan but given the
connection between violence and drug use
is this a good idea we asked new yorkers
what they thought are we now
criminalizing marijuana again no they've
legalized it here in new york in fact
your mayor your mayor just started a
program for safe drug use is that a good
idea yes it is i am of the opinion you
should have all drugs be legal tell me
your experience with crime in the city
you're in new york
yes
i i hate it the entire city is a jungle
and we are at risk i don't even take the
subway i'm afraid to go under the
general sort of
state of the city is
has slipped
it's dirtier
more homeless people in the recent
months definitely an uptick in crimes
myself i just got sped on by a homeless
dude
yesterday last night walking home
are you concerned by the rise in
marijuana use and other drugs you see
being employed right here in the park no
no no
i'm not i'm not worried about marijuana
use i don't think the people that are
doing these these crazy things with guns
are using marijuana they're using either
worse drugs or they're in psychosis
and they're they need mental health help
i was here under giuliani too and i saw
the absence of
the absence of
public drug use seemed to be the norm
then and now it's it's more it's
everywhere and i'm not just talking
about weed like they're strung out
heroin looking people
all over manhattan but when you learn as
i did recently the aurora shooter gabby
gifford shooter the shooter in texas the
parkland shooter all young men on
marijuana oh come on there's a psychotic
connection here
come on come on come on come on no i'm
not buying that i don't think marijuana
is that big of a deal i think that we
have a lot more problem with mental
health and people can't get prescription
drugs that they should be on because the
society we've built is
unlivable for most people can you drug
save no absolutely not you can't judge
safely it's a democratic approach which
is the destruction of the quality of
life for
conservatives and for law abiding
citizens
laura so many of these new yorkers do
not see the connection between the
criminality they're experiencing and
drug use they dismiss it but according
to the national institute of drug abuse
the high thc in marijuana today is four
times as potent as 1995's version and a
denmark study shows a four four-fold
increase in psychosis and schizophrenia
among pot users over the last 20 years
so it's not a stretch to see the
connection between this
it's more than not a stretch this has
been documented in study after study and
you know blowing off the connection
between increased chances to get
schizophrenia bipolar disorder uh to
develop psychosis i mean
we have many many examples of this we've
had doctors on who who've documented it
and who treat it in emergency rooms so i
mean the new yorkers uh you interviewed
some of them seem like they're great
people but they got to read more
understand more psycho psychosis doesn't
come out of nowhere okay not usually but
eric adams the mayor of new york sees
this as a cash cow he sees 1.25 billion
dollars in tax revenue once this is
legalized and dispensed here's the
problem they tried this in oregon this
almost got no coverage laura in 2020
they passed a measure decriminalizing
most drugs and all you had to do was
call a 1-800 number and you got a fine
if you were possessing it guess what
1885 people got fines 91 of them called
the hotline to get off the drugs today
oregon is the most addicted state in the
union almost 10 percent of people all
going down it's all going down under the
legalization effort raymond thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else